junkyard dog is often considered the
first
black superstar in wrestling even so as
with many wrestlers
there was a lot of tragedy behind his
smile
here are tragic details about junkyard
dog's life
football is one of the most common
athletic backgrounds for wrestlers
many of wrestling's biggest stars played
college ball and
spent some time at the pro level back
when junkyard dog was just sylvester
ritter
he was among this fraternity he was a
star offensive lineman at anson
county high school in north carolina and
continued his success at fayetteville
state
he then tried to continue his career in
the pros junkyard dog is often listed as
a green bay packers draft pick but
that's false on two counts first he was
never drafted
the name sylvester ritter doesn't show
up in any draft especially not from
1975.
second the packers were the second team
he was attached to
he started his pro career with a tryout
for the houston oilers in the summer of
75.
after not making the oilers he returned
home and played for the ohio valley
panthers of the carolina professional
football league
in april 1976 ritter was signed as a
free agent by the green bay packers
during an off-season camp ritter
suffered an injury and he was cut before
the season started
that injury spelled the end of his
football career luckily he had another
career waiting for him that brought him
greater renown than being a lineman
ever would i play a little pro football
so one thing lead to another junkyard
dog is remembered by most wrestling fans
as the sport's first black superstar
unless they're old enough to remember
bobo brazil as is always the case when
someone is the first black anything in
america
this came with a lot of racism pointed
his way junkyard dogs feud with the
fabulous freebirds may well have gone
beyond the normal scope of feigned
wrestling narratives wrestling historian
david shoemaker says the lillywhite
michael p
s hayes believed that black wrestlers
didn't need gimmicks because
black was their gimmick and was known to
freely use the n-word he often called
junkyard dog
boy he'll color commentator jesse the
body ventura was particularly vicious
yes he was playing a bad guy but he also
said that junkyard spoke like he had a
mouth full of grits
and referred to aspects of his in-ring
performance as
quote a lot of shuckin and jivin
kayfabe was still a key part of the
business during junkyard dog's heyday
which meant getting involved in some
scary situations
many heels of the era have stories about
being threatened
chased and attacked by fans stories they
often were with pride since having them
means they were doing their job
since junkyard largely played a face
little ire was directed his way
but on at least one occasion he had to
deal with a fervent fan with a weapon
one of junkyard's hottest angles was his
rivalry with the fabulous freebirds
in the most infamous moment the
freebird's blinded junkyard with hair
cream with junkyard claiming that he'd
never be able to wrestle again
or see the face of his newborn daughter
some fans expressed
sympathy by sending money to the
promotion address to junkyard dog
others took more direct action at some
point during this feud a fan jumped the
barricade during a show
pointed a gun at the free birds and
threatened to shoot them
thankfully arena security broke this up
before anyone got hurt
many wrestlers especially wrestlers who
peaked in the 80s were
heavy drug users junkyard dog was no
different
and his drug of choice was cocaine
junkyard's drug habits were known by
both his fellow wrestlers and promoter
bill watts
even so few could sell at an arena like
junkyard dog
while wwf wwe fans didn't know about
junkyard dogs predilections until years
later
the man's drug habits weren't much of a
secret among fans in new orleans
it was a much smaller community of fans
and wrestlers many of whom were aware of
junkyard dog's regular visits to drug
dealers
it's often said that wrestlers who win
championships have reached the
mountaintop
it's an apt metaphor not just because
it's an accomplishment but because
there's not much room at the top
in any given era in any given company
only a handful
of people are in the title picture at
any given time this
is especially true in the wwf wwe where
booking has more to do with how vince
mcmahon is
feeling that day than anything else this
was a ceiling junkyard dog faced in new
york
he may have drawn crowds to the
superdome in nola but he was just
another guy up north
junkyard's four year run in new york
lined up almost exactly with hulk
hogan's historic four-year stint as wwf
champion
the intercontinental championship scene
was made up of technically sound
wrestlers like randy savage
tito santana and ricky steamboat without
vince mcmahon's backing for the world
wrestling federation championship or the
in-ring skills for other titles junkyard
spent his four years as a mid-carder
that's not to say he was unpopular but
the company never allowed him to reach
the heights he did in mid-south
junkyard dog's cocaine use had many
nasty side effects but there was one he
couldn't hide
his weight game he used to be known for
his great physique but by the mid-1980s
he
ballooned commentators would often try
to cover for it saying that junkyard dog
was taking on weight because he was
facing off against bulkier opponents
like the one man gang
no amount of commentary gimmick tweaks
or territory changes could cover this
one up though
some wrestling magazines and newsletters
took to calling him junk food dog
it's hard not to think this contributed
to a ceiling in the wwf where mcmahon
has always shown a preference for tall
sculpted men over
smaller or even slightly pudgier guys
most wrestlers are in their prime at age
35
they're at their physical peak with
enough experience and respect that they
can practically book their own space on
the card
not so junkyard dog when he was axed
from wwf in 1988 as a cost-cutting
measure
his time anywhere near the main event
scene anywhere in america was done
not long after he was cut he joined the
nwa which soon became wcw
where he was given a main event run in
1990. this included an extended feud
with ric flair that was so poorly
received the wrestling observer
newsletter dubbed it the worst
feud of the year junkyard would spend
the next few years getting cut by wcw
and rejoining them largely due to his
conditioning and
low drawing power he spent the last few
years of his life touring the indie
circuit
a shell of his former self doing gimmick
matches with fellow legacy acts during
what
should have been his best earning years
even so he was clearly enjoying himself
as an international wrestling federation
promoter told the morning call
he enjoyed it all the big crowds the
small it didn't make
any difference as long as he was around
to sign autographs and take polaroids
with the kids
he also worked as a repo man to make
ends meet
on june 2 1998 junkyard dog was driving
home to mcgee mississippi from his
daughter's high school graduation in
wadesboro north carolina when he lost
control of his vehicle
the car rolled over three times and he
died in the crash
which occurred near forest mississippi
it's unknown why or how he lost control
though some reports indicate that he
fell asleep at the wheel
promoter guy walters told the morning
call that ritter specifically asked for
graduation weekend off
saying if that's the last thing in the
world i do i'm not
going to miss it grimly prescient words
but at least he lived to see it just
like he wanted
junkyard dog was 45 years old at the
time of his death
and condolences poured in from the
sports world
he was buried in his native north
carolina junkyard dog's popularity at
his peak
isn't just inflation of wrestling lore
it's empirical
fact around 1981 to 1982 new orleans
school children were polled about which
local athlete they'd most like to meet
this was at the tail end of archie
manning's nearly decade long run as
saints quarterback
and lsu scoring legend and new orleans
jazz guard
pistol pete maravich had just retired
but junkyard still
overwhelmingly won the poll he was also
a proven draw with at least
one estimate showing he drew a million
fans to the downtown municipal
auditorium over five years
recently however junkyard dog's name
doesn't carry the weight it used to
around new orleans
writer greg klein author of the king of
new orleans how the junkyard dog became
professional wrestling's first black
superhero
explained why to anti-gravity magazine
it's wrestling
a form of entertainment that is
disdained by the traditional media
it is also a form of entertainment that
has never had much in terms of history
in terms of celebrating its own
history the wwe owns the likeness right
so you can't just go
market the junkyard dog they don't do
much with their rights either so
nothing is out there klein has gone so
far as to push for a statue of junkyard
dog in louis armstrong park
wrestling fans from the territory days
are a dying breed
junkyard dog was dead when the attitude
era kicked into high gear so
at least two generations of fans never
even saw him wrestle live
most fans who do remember him still
think of him as the guy who's saying
grab them cakes on the wrestling album
at the very least jyd was posthumously
inducted into the wwe hall of fame in
2004.
if you or someone you know is struggling
with addiction
please call the substance abuse and
mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline at 1-800-662-help
that's 1-800-662-4357